il devrait être en train de fabriquer
des moteurs d'avion mais les
travailleurs de rolls royce sont en lock
out depuis un mois et demi la question
de la rémunération est au coeur du
litige le syndicat affirme que
l'employeur souhaite un gel salarial
pour les deux premières années de la
prochaine convention collective
c'est inacceptable c'est un non respect
pour pour aucun des salariés ici
l'article le coût de la vie a beaucoup
augmenté dans les dernières années
depuis la pandémie avec toutes les les
augmentations qu'ils soient
dans l'épicerie le galouzeau
jeu des balises aux salariés autrement
dit
au cours de la dernière décennie la
rémunération a progressé plus rapidement
que l'inflation au pays
les salaires ont augmenté de 23% dans
les milieux syndiqués et de 30% dans les
milieux non syndiqués des hausses
similaires ont été observées au québec
pendant ce temps les 10 des prix à la
consommation a grimpé de 16 pour ça mais
la tendance est en train de s'inverser
depuis un an les salaires ont augmenté
de 3,4 pour cent au canada de 5 5 % au
québec alors que l'inflation a bondi de
6,7 pour ça les travailleurs craignent
de perdre leur pouvoir d'achat est
possible d'échapper à cette réalité aux
tables de négociation c'est incroyable
le voit puis elle élit le niveau
d'augmentation est quand même plus élevé
sans nécessairement à côté du réel parce
que l'inflation particulièrement entre
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre hausse du coût
de la vie la pression monte pour que les
patrons offre de meilleurs salaires sans
quoi ils risquent de perdre leurs
employés des employés qui quittent ce à
un coût pour une entreprise c'est ça
coûte de l'argent aussi embaucher des
gens ça coûte de l'argent les former il
ya des employeurs qu'ils comprennent
plus que d'autres
en février un nouveau contrat de travail
qui comprend rattrapage salarial de 22%
pour la première année a été conclu chez
soucy international à drummondville les
hausses de 2 et demi à 3 % sont prévus
pour les années suivantes et pourrait
atteindre 4% si jamais l'inflation est
plus élevée un mécanisme d'ajustement a
été inclus selon le syndicat l'employeur
a fait des concessions pour retenir ses
employés j'ai la peau qui était à genoux
mais y était conscient de la
problématique parce que oui dans les
dernières années
on a perdu beaucoup d' expertise des
employés qui avaient des 15 à 20 heures
est-ce que trente ans d'ancienneté qui
ont décidé de quitter une entreprise
l'avocat richard goudreau conseil les
employeurs selon lui ils doivent
profiter de l'occasion pour moderniser
leur entreprise que ce soit par
l'automatisation ou encore la
réorganisation du travail ceux qui vont
donner des augmentations de salaire mais
qui en contrepartie vont fabriquer
productivité vont probablement se sortir
au mieux la situation actuelle que ceux
qui vont simplement céder à l'idée
d'augmenter les salaires les trois
grandes centrales syndicales du québec
vont faire front commun lors de leurs
prochaines négociations avec le
gouvernement dans le secteur public et
elles vont tenir compte de l'inflation
dans leur demande ici olivier machin
radio canada montréal